s c h
a n d e n f r e u
d e shed and freud it's when you it's
when you
enjoy someone else's misfortune
like like anyone who enjoyed that you
lost your spleen would have been
exercising schadenfreude yes they would
be
[Laughter]
oh off air i i was
anything you say can and will be used
against you in a court of law or on tv
i've yet to learn that after all these
years oh well
all right goats in a bad way time now
that we know how to spell and say
schadenfreude and what it means
uh some shot and freud i guess the goats
in a bad way for week 14. chris i'll
give you the first pick
oh well that's great thank you so much
because i'm going to go
directly to your favorite football team
in the whole universe the minnesota
vikings
and um say that your kicker dan bailey
would be the leader in the clubhouse for
goats in a bad way this week i mean
what the hell you got one job kick the
damn ball through the two yellow sticks
holy crapola batman i mean oh for four
on kicks
you kicked the ball four times oh for
four lose a game 26 to 14.
it was three field goals and one extra
point right mike i got that right i'm
pretty sure i know you were watching
closely and dying
the vikings there on sunday no i didn't
care i know i picked i picked the
buccaneers to win i wanted to be right i
was right
but that was that was horrible and yes
the
for them dominating the football game
early on the fact that he didn't give
them
points and give them that little cushion
early on and confidence and the boost
and everything like that
were a huge aspect in why tampa came
back easily and
and minnesota never really built the
lead they they should have with the
stats and the way they move the ball
well i i knew that you would make that
pick and
if i had made that pick i know what your
your pick would have been it's our
our new favorite actor from the 1980s
football movie jean
view nick mullins san francisco 49ers
uh look it's just over and i don't know
if you texted you got kyle shanahan
yesterday and told him just it's over
maybe he doesn't need the nudge it's
over not that cj beathard is
dramatically better but they got to do
something to hold this together until
jimmy garoppolo returns you and i both
thought there was a chance the 49ers
could get hot down the stretch
when we expect them to lose after a
rough game they tend to turn it around i
was stunned
that that game wasn't more competitive
from their perspective but
you know look nick mullins isn't the
answer i don't know that jimmy garoppolo
is the answer long term
nick mullins definitely chris is not the
answer no definitely not the answer
you know he he serves up plays for the
other team
you know time after time after time
there's a number of games this year you
can look at it and go
nick mullins is the reason they lost
there's no other reason
he's the reason and that was a game
there the other day where
like listen we talk about carson wentz
and understand the game right and manage
it and
know who you're playing on the other
side they if
if he was willing to and just protects
the football
they're going to win that game they can
win that game 13 to 10
you know 13 to 9. washington couldn't
move the ball at all they couldn't do
anything either
but the defense was constantly i mean
the washington defense constantly
you know made plays because of nick
mullen's fumbles interceptions whatever
and it's just set up for easy scorers so
yeah i'm with you i mean
it's to the point to where i just look
at i don't know how you can really throw
nick mullins out there again
the team has got to look at him between
the mistakes and big moments
and then the easy miss throws in the
competitive part of the football game
to go wait i don't know if this guy's
the right guy i don't think we can get
it done with him
and uh yeah so i'm mad you picked him
because i wanted to say it but i said it
anyway so
it's good you got to say it you at least
got to say it i gotta have sex
who do you want to say something bad
about next well i think that
i mean in the game that nobody wanted to
win right
you know it was like you know hey we're
the falcons and the chargers we like to
lose games in really cool ways
you win no you win you win you win i
just shocked by matt ryan's end of the
game performance he throws three
interceptions in the day
but two of them come on the last two
drives of the game
you know get down there they're getting
close to field goal range
interception now luckily justin herbert
throws one and gives it back to them
but then they get down there again in
their field goal range
and he throws some pop-up out route to
the right
and it's an easy interception for mike
davis and then justin herbert throws a
laser down the field and they're in
field goal position and they win the
game
but in the game in which hey we we are
the two teams that try to find ways to
lose every week
i mean matt ryan he's the one guy i
would go wait he's not going to make
that mistake it won't be him
so that that to me you know in a game
where you know they easily could have
won that football game and you don't
expect that mistakes he's he's a go to
the week for me
i gotta go with your guy john gruden for
mine
not because of what happened on sunday
although they lost and they're done
from a playoff perspective the idea of
firing the defensive coordinator on the
night after a game when you play a game
on thursday night
it feels a little scapegoaty to me it
feels a little let's not
have anyone scrutinize what i may not be
doing right on my end of the
the ball let's let's blame someone else
for what's gone wrong and
and i feel like maybe they're shifting
now that they are on the brink of their
third
failed season and if you don't make it
to the playoffs it's a failure gruden's
been back for three years now it's
amazing it's already
been three years it's gonna be oh for
three and the ultimate pass fail did you
make it to the playoffs
and i think he's getting to the point
where he's gotta look for other people
to blame
if i'm mike mayok i'd start getting a
little bit nervous because he may be the
next one to get blamed
but the first one is paul gunther and i
i think it's ludicrous to expect rod
marinelli
in three days monday tuesday wednesday
to get a team ready to go
on a short week even though they should
beat the chargers
they would have beat them with gunther
they should beat them with marinelli
this is more about
where this team is right now and i feel
like gruden's starting to feel the heat
a little bit
and you know he won't be on the hot seat
per se well who knows
who with mark davis who knows mark davis
may may
employ him for every game of that
10-year contract that he signed a few
years ago
but i feel like from a more perception
standpoint
and who outsiders are going to blame i
feel like he's trying to
to move the spotlight away from himself
and it and it manifested itself in a
stupid decision to fire your defensive
coordinator three days before a game
i mean i'm i'm surprised no doubt about
it i mean listen
i'm not going to sit here and go oh man
paul gunther's the best defensive
coordinator in football or anything like
that i mean it's not shocking like that
but yet
he's he's still serviceable it's good
you know
and to like to the points you make you
know first off like
you know one all right who is on that
defense that you think they're gonna be
so damn dominant
anyways who in the front seven you know
most most like
just johnny common fan who watches
sunday football and doesn't really pay
attention to idiots like you and me all
week or read pro football
talk i bet you a lot of them couldn't
tell you anybody who starts on the front
seven for the
the los angeles raiders so what makes
you
that's to me where i'm like what makes
you think that that was supposed to be
better and then i've had you know
friends and people go well their defense
has been so it hasn't been good lately
you know okay yeah the kansas city
chiefs moved the ball in them shocker
they moved the ball on everybody
historically great defenses they still
move the ball
the falcons lost where they got blown
out that wasn't the defense's fault
the offense repeatedly just screwed the
game up the defense actually played
pretty good
they can only hold the fourth down for
so long you know and then yeah okay the
jets game wasn't great so i'm with you
man i'm i'm shocked i really am i'm
surprised by it all um
let's see i got one more pick right i
think we got one more i think i got to
go back i'm going to go to the giants
new york giants offensive line here
this week the whole group across the
board you know that was just a
shellacking but what i saw there i mean
one the pass protection the eight sacks
uh
and and not that they were like eight
sacks where you're like oh wait the
quarterback didn't see that guy
or he should have known he was hot what
a dumb quarterback no it was just the
o-line getting their butts whipped
constantly you know across the board and
i can't really even sit there
and tell you one guy because i was
watching that game on sunday it was a
little bit of everybody
hassan riddick seemed like he got his
five sacks he got it i think against
three
different people so you know that the
way the run game looked they were just
totally dominated up front which is a
shock because the giants
o-line had been playing so well lately
but daniel jones his inability to move
either
you know maybe that compounds it but you
think that would make the offensive line
be a little bit more on their p's and
q's in a week like that
um but it was just bad all around look
the giants were asleep last week and got
their butts whooped in the trenches
you know i had joe judge on my list for
putting
uh daniel jones on the field at all yeah
like what he had no business playing and
it sounds like they're gonna try to push
him back out there again they're gonna
they're gonna accept a a guy who's
diminished over
a 100 backup and i know they're getting
desperate at this point but they're
potentially going to screw up their
playoff chances because
colt mccoy helped them win in seattle
that has to count for something
in this analysis all right last one for
me and we've talked about the steelers
struggles on offense and at some point
it's got to land
on the desk of randy fichner the
offensive coordinator
i mean he's the guy drawing up the plays
he's the guy who's got to get control of
ben roethlisberger and if you can't
that's on you you're the coach coaches
coach and players play and
and if there is a question of whether or
not ben is freelancing changing plays
the line of scrimmage whatever
you're the one who's got to find a way
to get through to him whether it's
through persuasion or brute force
right you've got to find a way to get
him to see it your way
and do things your way and you got to
get the offensive lineman you got to get
the
offensive line coach involved to get his
guys playing better so you can run the
ball
it all runs through you mike tomlin is
not an offensive coach
so it falls on the offensive coordinator
now it ultimately falls on tomlin
because he's the guy who hires the
offensive coordinator
but but for now fichtner is the guy who
needs to come into the spotlight in a
negative way because
he's the one who's responsible for this
offensive performance that has been so
bad chris yeah no they got to find a way
to fix it and yet communicate to big ben
hey listen short passing game we like it
but we got to do a little bit
more and they got to sell that to him
you know whether that's mike tomlin and
fichtner together to both make that type
of conversation
and really just frame it around hey we
can't do what we're doing
if we want to win the super bowl we got
to expand this or change things up a
little bit and hopefully they can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports